à quai à roseaux la capitale de la
dominique le paquebot saga saphir ses
625 britanniques ont traversé l
atlantique
depuis un an ils attendent ce voyage
mais pour accueillir ce bateau et ses
touristes à bord le gouvernement a dû
nettoyer la ville réparer le quai pour
assurer la sécurité des passagers
malgré les difficultés sur le terrain
cette compagnie voulait maintenir son
escale à la dominique
avec la saga saphir l'escale à la
dominique a été planifiée depuis
plusieurs années on est au courant qu'il
ya eu cet ouragan terrible mais après
concertation en interne on a voulu
maintenir l'escale on propose à nos
passagers une variété de différentes il
on savait aussi que la dominique voulait
que les croisiéristes reviennent pour
soutenir l'économie dans le marché des
souvenirs servant deux tentent de
reprendre leur activité économique
mais pour l'instant peu de paquebots
font escale et les touristes ne sont pas
dépensier il n'y a plus de bateaux qui
viennent ici comme avant la semaine
dernière il ya eu un bateau mais il n'y
avait strictement rien on vient avec 0
on repart avec zéro après l'ouragan
maria la dominique a perdu 90% des
escales programmées pour 2018
le sag a sapphire est le deuxième bateau
à faire escale sur l'île les bonnes
appréciations de cette compagnie sont
bons très importante pour la dominique
ouais